he's a busy man but taking time out for
us we appreciate that mike Mayock the
NFL Network providing live coverage of
the draft tonight starting at 8:00
Eastern Fox will air NFL network's
coverage of rounds one through three and
mike Mayock joins us now Mike good
morning thanks for joining us my
pleasure dan how you doing man I'm doing
okay the Josh Challenge story that broke
last night this morning does it have any
impact on your mock draft I don't think
so and this stuff happens every year
it's so frustrating
you know teams are gonna do whatever
work they have to do on it but it's just
my fact a bit sad if any of those tweets
are what they are but he's 17 girl kid
and we've all done some stupid things do
you think the Browns know who they're
taking yeah I don't think there's any
doubt that they're taking and at least
at number one and if you're John Dorsey
I think you're wide open for business at
four and I was trying to find a way in
my mock draft to trade down out of four
yeah and get Mike McGlinchey because I
think that's the perfect if they got
their cook back at 1:00 and filled that
left tackle spot with Joe Thomas was
that would be a home run so it wouldn't
even surprise me
for instance if Buffalo got up to say
six and then four because I'm not sure
Cleveland wants to go down to 12 because
they won't get McGlinchey at that point
give the audience your top five picks
you mean what I did last night yeah yeah
my mock yeah Cleveland at number ones if
Donald the Giants hit number two and I
think this is really where the trap
really starts because they could do
three different things but they're gonna
go with Lauren Barclay and my gut the
Jets at number three Broadway Baker
Mayfield Cleveland again could think of
moving down but if they stay there I
gave them Bradley tub at four in Denver
is another potential move down but I
think they feel like they're closer to
the Super Bowl team mostly years ago
than people think and they take the best
player in the draft available Quentin
Nelson guard Notre Dame how do the
Browns screw this up
I don't think they do I really believe
and I know that's kind of a talking
point but I don't think too much of this
phases John Dorsey he's been doing this
for 27 years he's very qualified he's
got little swag to him and I texted him
when he took the Cleveland Browns job I
guess hey Doris you have more salary cap
room and draft picks in any GM in
history don't screw it up I don't think
he will I really don't I think he's got
a lot of confidence and how he does
things very opinionated but at his core
he's a really good talent evaluator
talking to mike Mayock NFL Network the
quarterback who concerns you the most
there's five of them that everybody's
talking about for the first round and I
eliminate quarterbacks just like
evaluators do I eliminate people to get
the one I like but I'm concerned about
all I'm most excited and about one more
Jackson I am most excited to see what
happens to him over the next three fours
I think he's kind of a pro football
could be so I'm excited to see him I'm
very concerned about joshloz and not
because he doesn't have talent he's got
a ton of talent but I think he his
durability issues and inability to
protect himself in the pocket is a
little bit like Sam Bradford and they're
both gifted throwers when healthy but I
don't think he can answer the bell every
week yeah I'm right there with you on
the more Jackson you know I I love that
stock to invest in rosin I think the
fact he had two concussions this past
year I think that's been under played
Mike I you know we're talking about
other things with him and you know his
intelligence or his attitude and work
ethic and you know privileged background
but you know health would be the the one
thing I want to know about with Josh
Rosen I think you're right there and
I've been banging the table since day
one about that I don't I don't
understand why people think being
intelligent is a bad thing I I don't I
don't get that he's a tough kid just
like Sam Bradford is a tough kid but
he's got an inability to protect himself
in the pocket and hangs in there and
tries to make
in addition to the two concussions this
year he had the solar year before his
his down Shores
come up again you ask me you know what
worries me the most if I was em and I'm
making a top ten pick on a quarterback
that would scare the hell out of me to
be honest with and I like Baker Mayfield
a lot and I don't study anywhere near
what you do but the one concern I had it
felt like when the defense got tight
like when you disguised your defense or
Georgia started to play a little man
man-to-man coverage and then I solved it
I saw some cracks there with Baker
Mayfield it's hard to tell when they're
playing against big 12 defense if you
want to call it that but I thought when
they played against Georgia Georgia
tighten the windows there and all of a
sudden and he's gonna get that in the
NFL and so that was the only concern I
had now there's off the field or
personality okay but on the field if I
was assessing that was the one thing
that stood out there what do you see
when when with Baker Mayfield very
similar and I'll tape for me is that
three of the top quarterbacks in the
draft played against Texas Donald did
Mason Rudolph did and Baker Mayfield hit
and all three teams scored the least
amount of points they scored during the
year and all three quarterbacks
struggled for different reasons and
Texas plays more be one of the few teams
in the big 12 to place more of an NFL
style see like one high safety two high
safeties a very sophisticated sub
package defense and Baker may feel like
you know the zone blitz tough but the
NFL does all the time yes I mean they
intercepted him his job to pick sixes he
didn't see offensive ends dropping in
the flat it exploded and I'm not trying
to say he can't learn it because he
hasn't been exposed to it very often but
it's just one of those things where he's
gonna have to learn how to win in the
pocket against the kids in FL defense
here's one for you of these teams most
likely to draft a quarterback in the
first round
Ravens Steelers Patriots Chargers sinks
I think I've been talking about this
Lamar Jackson thing for a while now and
I think one of those themes you just
mentioned is gonna schematically and
philosophically commit to this kid which
is what it takes it's an organization
decision to go in a completely different
fashion
I gave Jackson in my mock draft to the
Baltimore Ravens at 16 and that would
mean Joe Flacco's is out after this year
and by the way they signs are great
which i think is also critical if you're
going to commit to the run scheme type
of thing for your quarterback so you
have a backup that can run the same
thing that your starter can and the
other one I think is Sean Payton and the
Saints and if they moved up and if they
moved up aggressively or Lamar Jackson
it wouldn't surprise me and keep in mind
their backup quarterback has Taysom Hill
who ran for four at BYU and he's a run
quarterback who takes special themes
last year for New Orleans so both
Baltimore and New Orleans could handle a
conversion once their quarterbacks are
done playing to a college type offense I
finally this and the most important part
of this any new draft jargon terms that
we need to be aware of waist bender
stiff hips heavy hands what is it
tonight Mike that we need to be aware of
I always try to get a people in but but
it's hard to get a taffy pull in when
you're only talking about one guy well
what's a tan people it's when an
offensive lineman and a defensive
lineman just like vigorously exchange
hand uses with no one getting an
advantage okay okay it's at a people
okay so but we might be talking glass
eaters tonight glass cedars how about a
steak eater steak eater
how about carnivore this this guy
Quinton Nelson's a carnivore it's a
little bit like rich I told me at the
combine when I said a guy was good in
the phone booth and he's like Mike
there's a whole generation here now I
don't even know what a phone
[Laughter]
which kind of brought me up short like
wow you're right but you did use heavy
hands last night I think were you
talking about Bradley chub or was that
Edmonds who has heavy hands yeah yeah I
think Bradley job like Joey Bosa has
heavy hands violent and an ability to
disengage especially in the run game
because you're heavy-handed okay heavy
hands well have fun tonight and we
appreciate your time thank you Mike and
you know what when you see it is that
the the Buccaneers are gonna who's
having a parrot come up there to Canela
period okay you're gonna have a problem
with that right listen when they went
back to the zoo for the third time last
year I had a problem I was good the
first two times but when they Grover
Stewart from Albany State heard his name
and we went back to the frickin zoo I
was like enough to know if the power
drops in once I'm good you know get the
parrot three times all bets are off all
right thank you Mike so you stay in a
good mood all right that's mike Mayock
NFL Network for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]